we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
will go to the 740 area code next caller
what's your name and where are you
calling from my name is rodriguez
william found in maryland awesome what's
on your mind yes note we plan to talk to
you David I've been a long time listener
first I'll call me today thank you I'll
just I'm just curious on what is
something that you expect to see no in
the first hundred days of a proper
administration yeah we'll listen Trump
has his hundred a plan so but if we
think Trump Trump is trustworthy and
reliable incompetent we don't have to
guess we just go and look at the first
hundred a plan obviously you and I know
uh that that's BS and that that a lot of
those things we're not going to see and
I see lots of other things so I would
immediately expect to see it's a
significant attack on the affordable
care act right away we're going to be
seeing that I would immediately expect
to see from attorney general Jeff
Sessions an attack on marijuana
decriminalization and legalization they
were going to see that pretty quickly I
would expect to see something on
immigration although it's not going to
be the Muslim ban and you're obviously
not gonna get a wall with Mexico built
in the first hundred days although they
may you know allocate some funding to
start building some fencing or something
like that I mean I think those are a few
things anything on your mind Pat that we
expect Trump to do right away anything
on the libel stuff with media I don't
know the the repeal of the Affordable
Care Act is going to be the first order
business cuz I think everyone in the
house and Senate's gonna be right on
that even when Obama was in office they
try to repeal it some 40 times yeah once
they have a Republican president office
I think that's gonna be the first order
business I would also be interested
Rodriguez and i'll let you jump back in
to see what if anything we see it
diplomatically done with Russia but do
we see anything happened with Russian
sanctions what what might we we expect
to see there what do you think well you
know when it comes to Russia st. ships I
don't think that he's going to try to
reverse anything that Obama did because
you know I think the Republicans
themselves would be
guess that made them have come out
nationally supported obama his decision
to arm places sanctions on Russell so I
don't believe that you know he would
even try to reverse that because he
would get opposition with all party yeah
i'm not sure i think slowly but surely
the republican party has gone from the
2012 party which agreed with mitt romney
that russia is the biggest geopolitical
foe to the 2016 Trump uh position which
is we may not like these people but
maybe it makes sense to just talk to
everybody which by the way was the
position of President Obama for a very
long time interesting Lee enough I think
you may see a split within the
Republican Party in terms of improving
relations with Russia but we will see
over the next hundred days thanks so
much for the call i really appreciate it
all right place all to you David have a
nice day ok youtube